At the core of is the pod.
Pods represent a logical application.
Pods represent and hold a collection
of one or more containers.
Generally if you have multiple
containers with a hard dependency on
each other, they would be packaged
together inside of a single pod.
In our example,
you can see that we have a pod that
has the monolith and nginx containers.
Pods also have volumes.
Volumes are just data divs that
live as long as the pod lives and
can be used by any of
the containers in that pod.
This is possible because Pods provide
a shared namespace for their contents.
This means that the two containers
inside of our example pod
can communicate with each other, and
they also share the attached volumes.
Pods also share a network namespace.
This means that a pod
has one IP per pod.
You know what?
Let's take a deeper dive into pods now.